kritik am brett city die fischer sehen
sich als verlierer der einigung
weihnachten in der pandemie der
bundespräsident wirbt für zuversicht
urbi et orbi im kleinen kreis der papst
segnet unter chor ohne auflagen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster
seien sie herzlich willkommen an diesem
ersten weihnachtsfeiertag und wir
beginnen mit der politischen nachricht
dieses weihnachtsfest dem rexit deal in
letzter minute
der neue handelspakt erspart nun beiden
seiten das chaos eines models wie er
genau aussieht darüber hat eu
chefunterhändler barnier die restlichen
27 mitgliedsländer heute informiert so
benötigen eu bürger ab oktober 21 einen
pass zur einreise nach großbritannien
die regierung in london zieht sich aus
dem europäischen studenten
austauschprogramm erasmus zurück und die
europäischen fischer befürchten große
verluste weil sie in britischen
gewässern weniger fangen dürfen oder
krüger berichtet der mann mit dem ertrag
ist da michelle banier am feiertag im
maschinenraum der eu die
botschaftertreffen den br- exit
unterhändler 1246 seiten keiner hat alle
gelesen aber alle stimmen für die
vorläufige anwendung ab dem 11
so kann der franzose werben um
zustimmung
es gibt keinen sieger beim black cit
alle verlieren die trennung schwächt uns
alle die briten wollen allein sein und
nicht mehr solidarisch
sie haben künftig weniger vom britischen
fischfang quoten sinken von holland bis
zur normandie ab montag 25 prozent
weniger
na gut wir werden versuchen uns
anzupassen wir haben keine andere wahl
und obwohl der fisch ist der sieg des
boris johnson
hier kommt die frohe botschaft ruft er
in der weihnachtsansprache ein vertrag
der wirtschaft und reisen sicherheit
kein brett chaos also zum bestehenden
corona chaos und doch ein austritt
bleibt ein austritt
deshalb wird es eben auch zusätzliche
bürokratische hürden für unternehmen
geben zollformalitäten papierkram
klemmen unterm arm von banier also die
bestmögliche lösung oder neue probleme
der erste erste wird zeigen
in den usa ist die stadt nashville von
einer explosion erschüttert worden
ermittler sprechen von einer
absichtlichen tat zunächst wurden
schüsse gemeldet danach ist ein flug
sein fahrzeug in einem touristen viertel
der stadt explodiert drei personen
wurden verletzt
die hintergründe sind unklar schauen wir
jetzt auf die krone zahlen in
deutschland
das robert koch institut registrierte
25.500 33 neue infektionen innerhalb
eines tages weitere 412 menschen starben
in verbindung mit dem virus allerdings
werden an weihnachten weniger daten
erfasst bundespräsident steinmeier dank
den menschen für ihre bereitschaft in
der korona pandemie rücksicht zu nehmen
und verzicht zu üben
man komme dem ausgang aus der krise
jetzt schritt für schritt näher sagt er
in seiner weihnachtsansprache und rät zu
mut und zuversicht für das kommende jahr
patricia wiedemeier
es waren tausende persönliche
botschaften zuschriften die den
bundespräsidenten in der adventszeit
erreicht hatten und die dann auf der
fassade von schloss bellevue zum
leuchten gebracht wurden
jede einzelne bezeichnend für dieses
jahr dass alle sich ganz anders
vorgestellt hätten so der
bundespräsident zu anfang seiner
weihnachtsansprache die pandemie hat uns
daran erinnert wie verletzlich wir
menschen sind aber etwas anderes haben
wir auch erfahren dürfen wie stark wir
sind wenn wir aufeinander achtgeben und
füreinander da sind
steinmeier bedankt sich vor allem bei
denen die bis zur erschöpfung arbeiten
und ihre eigene gesundheit riskieren den
ärzten pflegern erzieherin und
wissenschaftlern um nur einige wenige zu
nennen
unser land ist ein starkes land weil so
viele menschen für andere da sind und in
der krise über sich hinauswachsen
eine ganz wichtige lehre sei dass man
unserer demokratie vertrauen könne sie
funktioniere trotz zunehmender kritik
diejenigen die die gefahr des virus
leugnen sind zwar oft besonders laut
aber die vernünftigen sind die große
mehrheit
sie sorgen dafür dass wir menschenleben
schützen und die krise bewältigen können
die krise sie habe gezeigt wie viel man
miteinander bewegen können künftig
vielleicht auch im kampf gegen den
klimawandel oder gegen hunger und armut
die weihnachtsansprache des
bundespräsidenten sehen sie gleich nach
uns papst franziskus hat in seiner
weihnachtsbotschaft dazu aufgerufen die
korona impfstoffe zu teilen und allen
menschen zugänglich zu machen
seinen traditionellen segen urbi et orbi
spendete der papst in diesem jahr in
kleinerem kreis aus rom annette
hilsenbeck menschenleer ist der
petersplatz der balkon von dem der papst
sonst am weihnachtstag spricht leer
in diesem jahr wendet sich passt an
ciscos aus der benediktiner an die
gläubigen verkündet von hier urbi et
orbi den segen für die stadt und den
erdkreis der besagt dass alle sünden
vergeben werden
in seiner weihnachtsbotschaft mahnt der
papst eindringlich auch in schwierigen
zeiten nicht alleine auf das eigene
schicksal zu schauen anderen zu helfen
botschaft der geburt jesu wir können
nicht zulassen dass uns das virus des
radikalen individualismus besiegt um mir
gleichgültig werden gegenüber dem leiden
unserer brüder und schwestern die eine
päpstliche weihnachtsbotschaft geprägt
von der korona krise ein aufruf zur
nächstenliebe gegen egoismus und noch
das wetter für morgen im nordwesten
regnet es etwas sonst viele wolken
südlich der donau sowie in sachsen auch
länger sonnig höchstwerte minus zwei bis
plus sechs grad
das war es in aller kürze an diesem
feiertag wir danken fürs dabeisein und
wünschen ihnen vom gesamten 19 uhr team
ein frohes fest
ihr folgt jetzt der bundespräsident und
wir sehen uns morgen wieder wenn sie
mögen um 7